this was this proof this resulted was
actually only the first part of the
proof and I didn't finish off the second
part what they wanted was this is kind
of like I don't think they had labels
but this is part one part two so it was
not that they wanted you to prove
something but they want you to find
another expression for I am okay
importantly they wanted it to account
for N equals zero this one Italy counts
for N equals one and so on okay you can
sort of see that it can't account for N
equals zero because it will have I of
negative one in there and you can think
well it's going to actually follow some
different rules if what you've got here
is what would that be that'll be x over
1 minus excuse and then so on and so on
ok so the recurrence relation that we
got only works for is only true for of
values of N greater than or equal to 1
right so they want something they sort
of want to get away from the recurrence
relation I want to use this if I get
some other kind of expression that
doesn't depend on this and therefore
isn't bounded by this they want some
kind of attrition
that'll hold even including 0 ok now
heads up any we get this one did we get
there you don't have a look at it more
ever seen takeout
even you Beck's did you get it oh yes
I'm just my brain is just taking over at
the moment okay so here's the way that I
would think about this right do you
remember AC it's to the concert oh I
think back to where you've got just
regular integration by parts okay and we
we looked at questions like this we
would use recurrence relations for
something like
or something like this okay so what we
did was we saw that if we took the case
of sine X or to the N sine X right you
get your own currents relation you know
if we call this I five then there be an
eye for it and then by three and right
soon and I want eventually you get to
some point but you don't need to worry
about a recurrence relation anymore you
could evaluate you know say I
I want you could do write need your goal
of sine X to the power of one from
multiply G that's fine
we don't need any fancy intensities that
we can just evaluate it right so the
idea here is we're gonna take the same
principle we want to go all the way
using this identity until we get down to
something where we don't need to use the
recurrence relation anymore and we can
just see what it is okay so here's the
way we're gonna unpack it
this is I am I'm going to think of the
recurrence relation kind of like a young
kind like a ladder let's step down okay
so from this step I can go to the
previous step and know what that's like
I can know what by n minus 1 is because
it should follow the same pattern that
my n is right so in this case everywhere
I see n here I'm gonna stick in an N
minus 1 right so let's see what happens
you're gonna get three and by this 1
over 3 n minus 1 plus 2 by and now since
I'm looking at the previous one I'll be
what's the recurrence relation going to
look at this right ok hmm I'm just gonna
tighten this up a little bit for reasons
that will become clear shortly I'm just
gonna leave the numerator as it is I
didn't get much out of here let's go
down the bottom I don't wanna get rid of
that two and make it a little simpler
three and minus one brackets that's
three and minus three isn't it so three
and minus three plus two
what's that three and minus one yes
Alex all right and then you got your I
end by just you hanging over on this
side like it's the problems let's keep
going down the ladder right so the next
one will be I n minus 2 ok well the
pattern continues a lot of it just stays
the same
this is gonna be n minus 2 over now
what's gonna happen every time I go down
this thing the denominator is actually
as I consider each step down the ladder
they're related to each other right this
term this term and this term
what kind of secrets do they form come
on big to unit the difference between
this and this is negative 3
of course it's negative 3 because I have
minus 1 in here in this times 3 right so
this is going to be negative 3
again this is an AP isn't it very simple
stuff okay so therefore rather than
write the expansion under you can say
clearly that must be three and one is
four
right cuz you're gonna go three and then
three again and so on and of course you
need to look at the next step on the
ladder
alright good so I've got three steps the
top step the next one down and the next
one down after that I think that's kind
of enough here you know your way so the
three steps is kind of enough to see a
pattern establish where this will be the
AP or a GP or see what's going on here
now I want to go all the way down skip a
whole bunch of steps I want to start
getting toward the part of the
recurrence relation that I can actually
evaluate and don't have to keep on going
down the ladder I want to get off the
ladder right so let's see I need I want
about three so let's go let's go to line
three so I've skipped a whole bunch of
intermediate steps on the ladder right
because I assume they're gonna fit all
the same way at these hands okay what
does I three look like what are the
actual numbers cuz I can evaluate this
now right on the top you'll have no I'm
just gonna write that as 3 times 3 for
the same reason I did before what's on
the bottom no I'm - that's 11 isn't it
11
times I and now I can I can see the end
of the ladder it's kind of easy I'm
gonna get rid of this idea you can
evaluate though you don't need to wait
for me what's quite ooh
and I won and I know cones me thank you
okay
that's going to be three times to on
once when the denominator
they're always three left they eleven
and then eight you can see what the next
will be by one okay now at this point I
could sort of I could evaluate this
couldn't I by one think about what I won
looks like you can value it that's just
a polynomial isn't it it's a simple one
too but we want this to include I
thought okay so I'm gonna keep going I'm
gonna see what happens when I go all the
way down I won that's equal to according
to the recurrence relation it'll be
three times one on five okay and once
you get here for I thought you can't use
the recurrence relation anymore that was
kind of the point of this right so
therefore I'm just going to evaluate it
like from the integral from what my n is
okay so I know it is from the 1 to 1 X 1
minus X Q to the power of not because
it's I don't there you go
so that's one this is just x squared on
to isn't it yep okay yeah go all the way
back to the top and ladder right the top
run says it's this time to the next room
what's the next room look like well it's
this times the next row and with that
what's that look like it looks like this
time to and so on all the way until here
and after that I don't have to multiply
by anything else right because that's
not it stops so therefore I can say I n
is equal to right well I'll start with
that with this three and on three M plus
two now instead of writing the next run
I'm gonna say I'm gonna actually put in
what I worked out the next one was it's
three a times n minus one
on whether I get 3 and minus 1 times now
I could say the next run but I've
already worked out what found an x-ray
so I'm going to keep going ok 3 and
minus 2 on 3 and minus 4 okay now at
this point in going down the ladder
I said look all the steps are going to
keep on going I'm just gonna say they'll
all follow the same pattern
and I thought about what happens just as
I'm getting off ok what am I gonna go 3
times 3 3 times 2 on 8 3 times 1 on 5
and then I've got I not hanging off on
the end right which is a half okay now
admittedly this looks pretty awful right
it looks terrible
however the strength of this is that it
doesn't depend on a recurrence relation
anymore we've gotten rid of all of the
recurrence right I've gone down all the
way to I know so I can actually say that
this statement is true even for values
of n that includes 0 ok now have a look
at this though this is quite there's a
lot of sort of symmetry to this isn't it
there's lots of things that we can take
out for instance every single one of
these terms except that that one has a 3
in it right every single one except the
last one how many terms are there
excluding the half the either one how
many other well like I can count right
I've got one here 2 here 3 some number
I've got n minus 2 n minus 1
I've got any of them right and threes
all being multiplied together so I take
that to be 3 to the power of n right
once you factor out all of the threes
there are a lot of us right what do you
end up with on the top you've got in
times n minus 1 times n minus 2 times
whatever the next door be times 3 times
2 times 1 we have a name for this it's n
factorial okay that's kind of nice your
whole numerator collapses down into that
okay so that's it simplified
tremendously now you have a look at the
bottom unfortunately because of this sum
which is what's causing the problem
what's causing the problem is this guy
that plus two kind of throws a bit of a
spanner in the words right what you've
got here I mean it's an it's an AP right
but the terms it's an arithmetic
progression but it's not an arithmetic
series you're not adding up the terms so
I can't use some kind of formula to just
simply evaluate that it's a prat not a
son and because the gap of three in
between each one is up offset by two I
can't use simple factorial notation to
just sort of simplify it out so there
are some finicky ways to simplify it but
really it's enough just to say well this
is this product that I've got and it
follows this pattern all the way down to
your last three terms will be enough so
what is this this is an expression for I
in which we've used the recurrence
relation and we've used it till it ran
out which is why it doesn't have any
recurrence relation in it anymore and
I'm sure enough you can stick zero into
all of that is your factorials 1/3 to
the 0 is 1 and you'll get well what
would be the first time maybe two
so which makes sense because we already
know that PI naught is 1/2 so let me
just review what do we do okay you have
to do all the work to end up with this
recurrence relation but recurrence
relations will not be able to work for 0
because they're depending on some
previous term if this recurrence
relation for instance if it had like an
N minus 2 in it then it wouldn't even
work for N equals 1 right because then
if you had n equals 1 in there you'd
have a negative 1 and throughout the
power and you end up with a different
kind of integral right so all recurrence
relations end somewhere right but we can
use all the recurrence relations so that
we can get to the bottom ok you have to
evaluate these terms so you can see
where the where the whole ladder looks
like where you get rid of all of the
terms until you can get an actual value
of the year